so you got a lot of family in the
Philippines I have a question for you so
my mother and father were divorced many
years ago and my father remarried a
woman from the Philippines and brought
over her two kids from the Philippines
DJ and Mamie and they call me cool you
Tom
that's so cool so who has all their
brothers so I I'm gonna ask you this
point-blank
do you eat the chicken bones better
chicken eater yep
then my mother or myself or my sister in
fact I was flabbergasted the first time
I ever saw him eat a piece of chicken
[ __ ] what are you doing that's you ate
you ate nothing and he said no it's done
i'ma give me your [ __ ] bones I'll
show you how it's done
eat the cartilage and then you break it
because you suck the marrow doesn't come
out soft but you do have to suck on a
chicken bone for the flavor yes I did it
I did it when I was in Manila the I told
the story about my family and I I adore
them they're beautiful people but they
eat the chicken bones and you know when
when when when you and I eat chicken we
get to the bone and we say to ourselves
the meal is over people from the
Philippines saying we have now arrived
at the crunchy part we have nature pets
too right I started to be able the
Philippines around they get when they
get like I've brought up the bones thing
and they go that's the tastiest part
yeah you gotta eat all the entire animal
in fact we have names like when you go
on the side of the road and you see like
little we call them barbecue hon where
they barbecue like the meats on the side
and they have names for different
chicken parts so if you order Adidas
that's chicken feet if you order
walk-ins if you order the Walkman that's
more of like the chicken's head so you
know we like to utilize the whole animal
I love it so oh by the way I brought you
at my new album
it's called around the world and there's
the manila track is on there that's the
digital download
so my new album is called around the
world my wait so what okay is that what
you're here to promote this I just know
I know we're gonna say this tech-savvy
you're gonna get to that point or
something no no I wasn't even we were
talking about vanilla Tom Rhodes right
do you give me a business card varies I
know it's know Tom rose around the world
to digital download right Tom Rhodes net
is where they go right get the album on
the iTunes room is yeah and Amazon and
here's the vibe is my dad's my access
code right yeah this access code is mine
so I can just download it thank you
[Music]